[Musik]
seit Monaten sprechen wir über die
Bundeswehr und heute sprechen wir mit
ihr sozusagen
Generalleutnant Markus Laubenthal
stellvertretender Generalinspektor der
Bundeswehr herzlich Willkommen zu
phönix-persönlich vielen Dank für die
Einladung
Herr Laufental diese Woche ernährt sich
ja der Begriff der zeitenwände über die
wahnsinnig viel diskutiert worden ist in
den letzten Monaten es gibt eine ganze
Menge Lob es gibt aber auch viel Kritik
und der Grund Tenor der Kritik ist
Deutschland haben die zeitenwände
verschlafen wie sehen Sie das wie sieht
das die Truppe sind sie enttäuscht nein
enttäuscht bin ich nicht ich bin
enttäuscht über das Verhalten Russlands
diesen Angriff zu tun aber nicht über
die Reaktion die wir hier in Deutschland
gezeigt haben auch schon gar nicht die
in der internationalen Gemeinschaft ich
glaube das ist sehr sehr eindeutig diese
Geschlossenheit die an den Tag gelegt
wurde der Ukraine beizuspringen die
Unterstützung sozusagen die wir bis
heute durchhalten das ist glaube ich
bemerkenswert und ich glaube es ist
etwas
Putin unterschätzt hat womit er nicht
gerechnet hat und die Truppe reagiert
natürlich mit der gleichen Bestürzung da
drauf und ist sich sehr sehr bewusst was
das bedeuten kann sieht ihren Auftrag
noch mal mit einer anderen Sicht und
versucht natürlich alles zu geben
entsprechend auch zu reagieren was auch
getan haben denn wir sind ja bereits
auch seit dem 24.2 im Rahmen von
nato-maßnahmen tätig sozusagen von den
baltischen Staaten fast runter bis zum
Schwarzen Meer mit luftschaltkräften mit
heeresstreitkräften und auch mit der
Marine in der Ostsee und im Mittelmeer
kommen wir mal zum Geld es sollte ein
oder bzw es ist bereitgestellt worden
ein einmaliges Sondervermögen für
militärische Anschaffung in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro es heißt davon sind
minimale so ein bislang ausgegeben und
höchstens einige Verträge vergeben
worden das heißt es schleppt auch der
Nachschub schleppt was wissen sie
darüber wie ist der Stand es ist
natürlich so dass das eine gewaltige
Summe ist die uns sehr hilft dafür ist
die Bundeswehr sehr sehr dankbar über
diese Entscheidung des Bundeskanzler vom
27 Februar letzten Jahres das hat
wirklich einen einen Ruck gegeben bei
uns und es ist bei weitem nicht so dass
wir natürlich nicht tätig sind diese
Summe auch entsprechend zu veranschlagen
wir haben entsprechende Planungen exit
Listen die wir natürlich immer pflegen
und auf dieser Basis sind natürlich auch
viele Projekte in der Planung die wir
jetzt mit diesem Geld hinterlegen können
das heißt das ist ein echter Boost und
wir haben einen Großteil 30 Milliarden
bereits unter Vertrag bzw werden diese
Verträge in Kürze schließen ich rechne
da in 2023 nochmals an einem richtigen
Ruck das wird man auch sozusagen in der
Öffentlichkeit spüren im Parlament
spüren weil ein Großteil dieser
Genehmigung natürlich auch das Parlament
laufen werden und das setzt uns in die
Lage ein wirklichen Fortschritt zu
machen den Modernität aber auch in dem
Schließen von Lücken in der sogenannten
Vollausstattung das sind die beiden Kern
Defizite die die Bundeswehr natürlich
über die letzten Jahre entwickelt hat
wir haben in der Vergangenheit da schon
einiges getan muss man sagen seit 2014
seit der illegalexion aber eben mit
einem Finanzrahmen der eben nur kleinere
Schritte langsamere Schritte zugelassen
hat das ist jetzt noch mal ein echter
Boost den wir auch deutlich früher noch
in dieser Regale bei der Truppe
natürlich trotzdem vielen nicht schnell
genug 100 Schaden ist eine Menge Geld
wenn man sieht bislang ist es ja fast es
hat sich geehrt der Angriff Putins auf
die Ukraine warum geht das so schleppen
das heißt immer ja das Beschaffungswesen
sagen Sie uns doch vielleicht in drei
Sätzen mal wie ist denn so ein Vorgang
ich weiß drei Sätze ist gemein aber
drei Sätze für so ein komplexen Vorgang
ist ist wirklich gemein ich versuche es
aber mal auf auf den Punkt zu bringen
Munition können Sie nahezu aus dem Regal
kaufen dafür haben wir Rahmenverträge
weil wir natürlich auch sehr viel in der
Ausbildung verbrauchen dazu sind
entsprechende Produktionskapazitäten
vorgehalten vermutlich jetzt auch nicht
genug weil eben viele viele Kunden auf
die auf die Anbieter zustürzen aber das
ist ein relativ einfacher
Beschaffungsvorgang ein Waffensystem wie
ein Leopard oder die Nachfolge unseres
Maß Raketenwerfers die wir auch an die
Ukraine geliefert haben das ist dann
schon eine besondere Frage weil dieser
Maß z.B nicht mehr nachbeschafft werden
kann weil er einfach nicht mehr gebaut
wird das heißt wir müssen uns noch etwas
anderen umschauen und da ist dann die
die drei Kernfragen die man sich stellen
muss dabei ist
wollen wir das gleiche System nochmal
wenn es da ist verfügbar ist die
Produktion laufen kann dann ist das der
schnellste Weg wollen wir etwas
moderneres weil wir einfach in die
Zukunft auch schauen müssen denn es geht
ja nicht nur um das Ausgeben von Geld es
geht um Menschenleben am Ende wir
starten die Truppe damit aus und die
letzte Frage ist am Ende des Tages
finden wir Partner dafür dass wir das
vielleicht in eine Gemeinschaft
Finanzierung kriegen weil das sind
natürlich schon unseren die auch für
diese Systeme aufgerufen werden und das
erfordert dann schon eine gewisse
Gründlichkeit und da bin ich
nun in den Prozess regelmäßig
eingebunden das erfahre ich auch von der
Truppe die Truppe versteht das weiß
warum das geht die Probe schaut
natürlich wann wird ein Vertrag
geschlossen weil sie dann sicher gehen
kann dass das Material auch kommt und
dann liegt es eben an der
lieferkapazität der Hersteller wie lange
ist wirklich braucht ist etwas da ist
zugleich trifft ja jetzt diese Situation
ungünstig auf die Tatsache dass die
Bundeswehr offenbar in den letzten
Jahren in einem relativ hohen Zustand zu
geraten ist oder zu sein scheint es
heißt es gibt nicht mal Skiausrüstung
für Gebirgsjäger oder Teile des
kriegsgeräts das vorhanden war sei gar
nicht einsetzbar in welchem Zustand ist
die Bundeswehr denn wirklich wer
versandsminister hat es ja gesagt wenn
wir auf die Gänze der Bundeswehr schauen
dann haben wir noch sehr sehr viel vor
uns haben wir noch einen weiten Weg zu
gehen ich will aber auch betonen dass
wir mit der Bundeswehr in den letzten
Jahren immer unsere nato-verpflichtungen
erfüllt haben hier sind jetzt mit etwa
16,5000 Soldaten und Soldaten in der
schnellen Eingreiftruppe in der
Speerspitze der NATO in der sogenannten
vjtf-begriff wir haben am 24 reagiert
mit Luftstreitkräften die sind wenige
Stunden nachdem die der der
kriegsaufbruch passiert ist die
entsprechenden politischen Freigaben
dabei sind sie gestartet wir haben mit
dem sogenannten petri-verband der ja
auch nun in aller Munde ist haben wir
zweimal innerhalb eines Jahres sehr sehr
schnell reagiert einmal in der Slowakei
und jetzt über Weihnachten sozusagen
auch in Polen also das was von uns
verlangt wurde das haben wir immer
erfüllt und das findet auch
internationale Anerkennung nur das ist
eben jetzt nicht mehr genug die Nato hat
ein neues Profil angenommen wird ein
neues Profil angeben die NATO wird
höhere Anforderungen stellen an ihre
Mitgliedsnationen und da werden wir
diesen Anforderungen entsprechend auch
gerecht werden müssen und das erfordert
diese Sondervermögen und auch noch mehr
darüber hinaus zugleich sind sie haben
es gerade schon angedeutet natürlich
auch Lücken entstanden durch
Materiallieferungen an die Ukraine viele
Menschen machen sich Sorgen dass die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit Deutschlands
dadurch nicht mehr gegeben ist das heißt
Sie hätten zwei Luftabwehrsysteme gehabt
in der Bundeswehr die sein nach Kiew
gegeben worden es gibt Berichte Berlin
sei im Falle eines Angriffs dadurch
nicht mehr verteidigungsfähig auch der
Verteidigungsminister scheint hinter
verschlossenen Türen gesagt zu haben
dass sie die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
Deutschlands in Gefahr sieht wie
beurteilen Sie diese Frage also die
Verteidigung von Bündnispartnern findet
immer im Bundesstaat das ist Gott sei
Dank nicht Deutschland alleine sondern
da wissen wir uns mit dem
Verteidigungsbündnis unsere Allianz da
wirklich in einem sehr der sicheren
Umfeld das hat die NATO immer bewiesen
wenn sie gefordert wurde wir haben auch
zur Zeiten des Kalten Krieges viele
viele Bündnispartner auf deutschem Boden
gehabt hier stationiert gehabt also eine
Verteidigung Deutschlands nur mit der
Bundeswehr das wäre nicht möglich das
geht nur gemeinsam das ist aber zugleich
auch die Stärke der NATO und da gilt es
eben drauf aufzusetzen und hier gilt es
auch die entsprechenden Beiträge die
steigenden Beiträge jetzt noch in dieser
Dekade dann auch entsprechend zu
erfüllen dazu tun wir alles Notwendige
mit anderen Worten noch mal ganz kurz
zurück Deutschland wäre auf die partout
in der NATO angewiesen Deutschland ist
auch die NATO angewiesen
wie beurteilen sie denn die Lage von
oder bzw wie kommen wir zurück zur
Ukraine wie beurteilen Sie die Lage dort
im Moment welche Informationen haben sie
da und wie würden sie das Einschätzen
das was wir aus der Ukraine hören und
viele unserer Stellen im Ministerium und
auch darunter gerade jetzt bei der
Ausbildung die stattfindet sind
natürlich sehr intensiv mit den
Ukrainern den Kontakt das was die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte leisten sollte
mir allerhöchsten Respekt ab und das
Teilen auch unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten wie sie ihr Land verteidigen
mit welcher Motivation mit welcher
Überzeugung mit welcher Hingabe muss man
sagen sieht das tun das ist sehr sehr
beeindruckend sie brauchen die
Unterstützung der internationalen
Allianz die voll hinter ihr steht um
diesen Krieg führen zu können um
Russland abwehren zu können um ihren
Territorium zu behaupten und das machen
sie in vielen Fällen auf geschickte Art
und Weise und da können wir sicherlich
das ein oder andere auch lernen weil
dort eben Beschaffungsvorgänge dann
viele viele Busspuren finden und viele
viele Genehmigungsverfahren vielleicht
gar nicht mehr an den Tag gelegt werden
um eine Fähigkeit schnell in die Truppe
einzuführen darum wird es gehen da
schauen wir uns auch genau an so wie den
Einblick bekommen und das was wir von
den ukrainischen Soldaten hier auf
deutschem Boden hören die durch uns
ausgebildet werden ist das was wir Ihnen
an Technik zur Verfügung stellen
wirklich noch mal eine neue Qualität auf
dem Gefechtsfeld mit der sie sich dann
auch sehr sehr sicher fühlen auch den
Umgang da sehr gut lernen können und
dann auch hoffentlich auf dem effektfeld
den Unterschied machen dann gab es in
Deutschland ja lange
Diskussionen um die mir Lieferung der
Marder danach kam die Diskussion um die
Lieferung der Leoparden jetzt haben wir
die Diskussion um Lieferung von
Kampfjets wie schätzen Sie das ein
würden Kampf jetzt praktisch die Game
changer wenn man es überhaupt so sagen
darf wenn sie meinen Krieg geht oder
könnten die den Wendepunkt bringen nein
ich glaube das an einem Waffensystem
fest zu machen dass das greift zu kurz
das wäre sehr spekulativ ich denke was
die Ukraine von Beginn an brauchte war
die Fähigkeit ihren Luftraum zu
Verteidigung um sozusagen die russischen
luftschreibkräfte außerhalb der Ukraine
zu lassen das hat zum einen den Effekt
dass die russischen luftschaltkräfte
ihre Bodentruppen nicht nur unterstützen
können und damit auch einen wesentlicher
Teil der Effektivität der sogenanntes
einsatzwertes sowie wir das nennen dann
auch reduziert ist und das den Ukrainern
gewisse Vorteile in der in der Abwehr
ermöglicht und das haben sie mit
luftverteidigungsmitteln getan da haben
wir entsprechend unterstützt mit einem
Luftabwehrsystem was direkt von der
Industrie geliefert werden konnte wir
werden in Kürze wieder unterstützen mit
einem petri-system auf diese Ausbildung
läuft gerade in Deutschland und das sind
die Fähigkeiten die wirklich den
Unterschied machen es gibt Geparden
sozusagen das ist das was die Bundeswehr
als Fähigkeit verloren hat leider muss
man sagen der mit Industrie
Unterstützung bereitgestellt wurde der
wirklich den Unterschied macht und das
ist etwas was der Ukraine eben hilft
auch ihre abwehrfähigkeiten ihren
Einsatzwert zu erhalten
ja auch darüber ob wir überhaupt Waffen
liefern sollten
Sahra Wagenknecht und alles schwarzer
haben einen Manifest für den Frieden
vorgelegt das etliche Menschen
unterschrieben haben es gibt
Demonstrationen in Berlin
wie kommt das an bei den Soldaten und
Soldaten nehmen Sie das wahr wird
darüber diskutiert in der Bundeswehr die
Bevölkerung scheint ja da auch durch
ausgespalten zu sein also diese Sorge
ist glaube ich überall verständlich
jeder der die die Bilder jetzt aus
bachmut die Bilder aus Kiew die Bilder
aus der Ukraine sieht der macht sich
natürlich große Sorgen über das wie es
dort weitergeht über die eigene Rolle
das eigene Land wird man hineingezogen
oder nicht ich glaube das ist völlig
verständlich im Grunde ist eigentlich
jeder friedensaufruf zu begrüßen es muss
aber am Ende ein gerechter Frieden sein
ich glaube das hat er der Bundeskanzler
heute auch zum Ausdruck gebracht das
kann nicht zulassen der Ukraine gehen
sondern das muss etwas sein wo auch die
Ukraine selbstbestimmt sagt jetzt ist
der Zeitpunkt gekommen wo ich ihn
entsprechende Verhandlung eintreten kann
und wir unterstützen die Ukraine
politisch und wir Bundeswehr versuchen
all das zu leisten was wir im Rahmen der
militärischen Unterstützung leisten
können dass wir selber abgeben können wo
wir mit Ausbildungen helfen können und
ich glaube das ist der richtige Weg aber
wenn die Gesellschaft so diskutiert und
so uneinig ist wie ist das für die SOL
Martin und Soldaten die jetzt
ausgebildet werden aber auch die die
schon lange Dienst tun wünscht man sich
da nicht vielleicht eine eindeutige
Rückendeckung oder wie wird das bei
ihnen diskutiert also ich glaube wir
haben Rückendeckung in der Bevölkerung
das stellen wir mit unseren eigenen
Umfragen jährlich immer wieder fest die
ist auch in den letzten Jahren gestiegen
das hat sicherlich auch etwas zu tun mit
unserer Unterstützung in der
corona-pandemie das hat sicherlich etwas
zu tun mit der schnellen
Reaktionsfähigkeit helfende Hände und
technische Möglichkeiten bei der
schweren Naturkatastrophe im Ahrtal und
auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen und das
natürlich auch etwas zu tun dass die
Bevölkerung wahrnimmt was die Bundeswehr
leistet im Rahmen der Unterstützung der
Bündnispartner der Rückversicherung
unsere Bündnispartner an der der
Ostflanke der sogenannten Ostflanke der
NATO denn da sind wir auch tagtäglich im
Einsatz das spürt man und wir sind uns
der politischen Unterstützung bewusst
und wir sind auf der Bevölkerung
Unterstützung bewusst
und bilden sie ja seit Monaten
ukrainische Kameraden aus wie läuft das
ab was bilden sie da aus an welchen
Waffensystemen bilden Sie aus erzählen
sie uns ein bisschen also das sind die
Systeme die wir jetzt entschieden haben
also zum einen bei den landsystemen
Panzer Maler und es ist der Kampfpanzer
Leopard bei der Luftwaffe ist es jetzt
auch das System petriert und die bilden
wir sozusagen in den Gruß aus also wie
fahre ich das Gerät wie schließe ich mit
dem Gerät viel wichtiger ist aber noch
weil das kann man relativ schnell tun
viel wichtiger ist noch dass wir die
technische Ausbildung also diesen diesen
Grundstück dieses Basiswissen so
schaffen dass sie in der Lage sind
gewisse Instandsetzungsmaßnahmen vor Ort
durchzuführen und bei einem anderen was
darüber hinausgeht wo wir auch selber
eine Industrie Unterstützung brauchen
versuchen wir das dann sozusagen im
Ausland wahrzunehmen also konkret in der
Slowakei beziehungsweise die
Bündnispartner in Polen und wie läuft
das ab wie ist das Miteinander das ist
ja schon eine besondere Situation das
ist eine besondere Situation wir wir
lernen wir hören natürlich das was sie
auf dem Gefechtsfeld erlebt haben wir
versuchen das in unserer eigenen
Auswertung mit zu übernehmen versuchen
das in Verfahren umzusetzen bringen
Ihnen natürlich neben dieser technischen
Ausbildung auch bei wie man mit diesem
modernen Waffensystem und das spiegeln
sie uns immer wieder wie man mit diesen
modernen Waffensystem taktisch umgehen
muss also wie muss ich sie einsetzen
damit ich wirklich überlegen bin und
einen Vorteil habe denn das ist
sicherlich auch an ein wesentlicher
Beitrag damit ich im Einsatzwert steige
und dieses System dann auch erfolgreich
einsetzen kann das heißt sie lernen wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe auch
voneinander
klar ist natürlich auch dass das Kampf
erprobte Männer sind was ja die
wenigsten Soldaten und Soldaten in
Deutschland bislang kann man sagen oder
wie auch immer hoffen von sich nicht
behaupten können von dem Hintergrund der
politischen Debatte und vor dem
Hintergrund dass wir inzwischen viel
weiter sind als wir noch vor zwei oder
drei Jahren gedacht hätten was die Frage
von Militär und so weiter angeht können
Sie sich vorstellen dass es in den
nächsten Jahren doch dann auch wieder zu
Kampf einsetzen deutscher Soldatinnen
und Karten kommen wird das will ich
nicht hoffen ich will es mir auch gar
nicht vorstellen wir müssen aber alles
tun damit wir unsere Streitkräfte darauf
vorbereiten dass wenn so etwas passiert
wir reagieren können weil wenn wir das
demonstrieren dass wir das können diese
abschreckungsfähigkeit und da sollten
wir eigentlich immer besser sein als der
Tiran oder Diktator oder sozusagen der
der der Gegner der so etwas versucht um
ihn glaubwürdig abzuschrecken also der
der Wert der strandkräfte besteht zu
einem hohen Anteil in der
abschreckungsfähigkeit und das bedeutet
man muss glaubwürdig sein ich muss gute
Technologie haben überlegene Technologie
überlegene Ausbildung ich glaube das
haben wir Deutschen das haben unsere
Nato-Partner die ähnliche Systeme
Ausbildungssysteme fliegen und das macht
am Ende den Unterschied und das setzt
dann unterstreicht dann auch die
Glaubwürdigkeit wie würden Sie denn die
Frage definieren oder wie würden sie es
definieren zu sagen ein Land ist im
Krieg wir haben da unterschiedliche
Interpretationen sicherlich
international unterschiedlich weltweit
Putin beispielsweise sagt allein die
Waffenlieferung reicht schon aus Westen
im Krieg ist wie ist da ihre Definition
also völkerrechtlich glaube ich ist das
recht einfach wie unterstützen die
Ukraine in ihrem Abwehrkampf wir nehmen
nicht teil einer aktiven Kampfhandlungen
wir sind keine Kriegspartei und wir
wollen auch keine werden und ich glaube
da darf ich die ganze NATO mit
einschießen das ist die die Politik die
betriebene das ist die Linie die wir
verfolgen das macht man mit Augenmaß
gerade bei politischen Entscheidungen
international deswegen ist die
Abstimmung so besonders wichtig wir
machen das also bei den
Unterstützungsleistungen über das
Rammstein Format und das nimmt dann auch
die ein oder andere Zeit in Anspruch das
ist aber wichtig damit man sich sicher
ist und damit man möglich auch einig
also in der Mehrzahl dieser Entscheidung
dann dann trifft also man fliegt da die
gleiche Auffassung international ist ja
Moment auch einiges los man hat das
Gefühl dass die verschiedenen
ich weiß nicht ob man Blöcke schon sagen
kann sollte man vielleicht nicht aber
schon Verbündete suchen Bundeskanzler
Scholz ist jetzt am Wochenende bei
beiden in den USA gleichzeitig gibt es
Kontakte zwischen Moskau alles schauen
nach China wir werden die Chinesen sich
verhalten die in der halten sich zurück
und sagen wir bleiben hier neutral und
wollen sowohl mit dem Westen als auch
mit Russland weiter Geschäfte machen die
beobachten Sie das in der Bundeswehr
also wir sehen natürlich die Bemühungen
die in der Diplomatie die die Politik
betreibt ich glaube das ist auch wichtig
diese Geschlossenheit ist sehr wichtig
und je mehr Staaten auf der Welt sich
entschieden gegen diesen Angriffskrieg
Stellen desto wichtiger ist das das
bringt am Ende Zusammenhalt das entzieht
noch mehr Legitimität aus dem was Putin
vielleicht denkt dass er hat und das
muss immer wieder versucht werden das
ist ein konstanter Prozess ich will da
nicht vorgreifen wir beobachten das und
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass das
leider betrieben wird nun in der letzten
Wochen angekündigt auch das letzte große
atomare Abrüstungsabkommen News da hat
auch noch auszusetzen
was bedeutet das für die atomare
Bedrohung die von Moskau ausgeht in
ihren Augen also diese
[Musik]
Rhetorik der Eskalation die ist glaube
ich in dieser Logik der
nuklearstrategien angelegt sie muss
immer ernst genommen werden also wenn
Putin und das hat er ja schon einige
Male getan da Unsicherheit erzeugen will
also ein keiltreiben will in die
Geschlossenheit der internationalen
Gemeinschaft durch solche Drogen dann
ist das ernst zu nehmen darauf muss man
sich einstellen und das muss man mit
entsprechender politischer Balance auch
immer wieder ins Kalkül setzen aber
insgesamt sind es eher politische
Druckmittel und keine Waffen die man
einsetzt weil ich glaube auch eher
zutiefst davon überzeugt ist dass der
Schaden auch für ihn viel größer sein
wird als der Nutzen denn sowas passiert
also darauf setzt man eben auch durch
die nukleare Abschreckung die in der
Natur auch funktioniert
sie selbst waren ja auch ein
Auslandseinsätzen sie waren im Kosovo
und in Afghanistan wir haben jetzt
letzte Woche in der UN gesehen dass ein
Land wo die Bundeswehr auch im Moment
zumindest noch wertvolle Unterstützung
und Hilfe leistet nämlich
eindeutig hinter Putin gestellt hat in
der in einer Abstimmung
wir empfindet man das als
der Abgesandte eines Landes der doch
irgendwie in diese Länder geht um da
Hilfe zu leisten
das muss ja doch Schmerzen so was oder
macht sie das wütend nein das enttäuscht
ganz sicher
viele solcher Entscheidungen bahnen sich
ja über Monate an sind dann am Ende
keine Überraschung auch da wird immer
versucht diplomatisch darauf einzuwirken
durch politische besuche die
stattgefunden haben in der jungen
Vergangenheit ich bin selber vor kurzem
am Kontingent gewesen in ingao hat mit
den Solarzellen Soldaten sprechen können
und die sehen das natürlich mit großer
Sorgen um ihn noch größere Enttäuschung
weil sie sozusagen sagen wir leisten ihr
Dienst wir versuchen diesem Land zu
helfen und am Ende wird diese Einsatz
wiedergewürdigt noch Wetter am Ende
gewollt und das ist etwas worüber wir
uns natürlich immer auch Gedanken machen
müssen und das führt dann auch zu
politischen Konsequenzen also sollte
aber immer versuchen den
Gesprächspartner nicht abreißen zu
lassen diplomatie ist wichtig zu jeder
Phase um diese Dinge eben immer zu
begleiten und doch noch Überzeugung zu
lassen dass man seine Meinung kandidiert
und kommen wir zurück zu zum Zustand der
Truppe wie steht es um ihre
nachwuchsmöglichkeiten wir haben ja die
Wehrpflicht ausgesetzt oder Deutschland
hat die Wehrpflicht ausgesetzt im Jahr
2011 im Moment gibt es wieder eine
Debatte ob die ob es wieder die
Wehrpflicht wieder eingeführt werden
soll wie ist es bestellt und der
Nachwuchs wie ist die Nachfrage also es
ist eine sehr harter Wettbewerb um die
klügsten Köpfe und die geschicktesten
Hände indem wir uns befinden die müssen
wir uns stellen ich glaube wir sind ein
sehr attraktiver Arbeitgeber weil wir
interessante Verwendungsmöglichkeiten
bieten weil wir jungen Menschen das
bieten wonach viele suchen eben
frühzeitig Verantwortung zu übernehmen
mit entsprechender Technologie umgehen
zu können und vielleicht auch den ein
oder anderen Unterschied zu machen in
der Aufgabe in der Tätigkeit die ich
ausführe an etwas teil zu haben wo man
etwas bewegen und etwas verändern kann
und deswegen ist es immer wichtig dass
man auch mit diesen Attribut wird dass
man möglichst auch junge Menschen die
Gelegenheit gibt sich das vor Ort
anzugucken da gibt es unterschiedliche
Modelle dass sie auch ein
Freiwilligendienst anbieten der relativ
kurz getaktet ist also den freiwilligen
Wehrdienst oder auch jetzt den
Freiwilligen für den Heimatschutz zwei
unterschiedliche Modelle wo junge Soldat
in und Soldaten nach relativ kurzer Zeit
schon eine Aufgabe wahrnehmen können und
von dort aus haben wir eben auch viele
Möglichkeiten oder die jungen Menschen
viele Möglichkeiten sich in
entsprechende Länge dienende Verwendung
bei der Bundeswehr zu entscheiden und
sich dort hinein zu bewegen worauf
achten sie denn bei der Auswahl ich
meine nehmen natürlich wahrscheinlich
physischer guter Verfassung ist es ja
auch ein bestimmten eine Frage der
Mentalität oder der psychischen
Verfassung und wir müssen sagen dass in
diesen Zeiten in denen es jetzt diesen
Krieg gibt in Europa natürlich die
Grundvoraussetzungen sich auch verändert
haben am Ende muss sie ja im Moment doch
immer mitschwingen oder ist es
vielleicht deutlicher als je zuvor dass
es natürlich auch schlimmstenfalls um
töten geht
ja ich kann deutlich sagen aus meinen
vielen Besuchen die ich regelmäßig bei
der Truppe mache und da schließe ich
jetzt mal die Reserve mit ein bei den
Reserveeinheiten wir haben tolle Frauen
und Männer in der Bundeswehr sowohl die
Jungen die wir einziehen die zu uns
kommen als auch die die dann später die
Bundeswehr verlassen haben und den
Reserveeinheiten tätig sind da ist
höchste Motivation seine Vielfalt auch
von beruflichen
Kapazitäten und Kompetenzen diese
mitbringen die wir auch bei den
Streitkräften verwenden können und
darauf müssen wir achten dass wir das
weiter tun wir haben in vielen vielen
Bereichen die Möglichkeit auszuwählen
das kommt dann einfach bewerberaufkommen
noch hoch in einigen ist es deutlich
härter müssen mehr Anstrengung
unternehmen in den Bereich des
its zum Beispiel vielen technischen
Bereichen wo wir eben natürlich in der
nationalen Konkurrenz sozusagen viele
Weltmarktführer in Deutschland natürlich
entsprechend attraktiv bleiben müssen
also das versuchen wir wir versuchen
diese Angebote zu gestalten dazu kommt
häufig für den jungen Mann oder die
junge Frau dieser Militär Respekt ich
mache einen Unterschied ich stehe in
Verantwortung ich stehe mit meiner
Uniform für die Freiheit und die
Sicherheit Deutschlands für die
internationale Gemeinschaft und das ist
etwas was viele Menschen dann auch
erfahren wenn sie bei den Streitkräften
sind und sagen das ist eigentlich noch
mal etwas ich habe mir das gewünscht ich
habe mir das vorgestellt aber hier
erlebe ich das noch mal weil sie eben
relativ schnell damit konfrontiert
werden schon in der Ausbildung setzen
sie selber noch nicht in diesen
Einsätzen oder in diesen einsatzaufgaben
stecken aber sie erleben natürlich durch
den Ukraine Krieg sie erleben durch die
einsatzkontingente die wir nach wie vor
noch stellen sie erleben wie diese
Arbeit wie dieser Beruf diese Berufung
wirklich sich gestaltet sie sagten
gerade eben gerade im Bereich IT ist das
schwierig da stellt sich natürlich
sofort die Frage sind sie denn gut noch
geröstet und aufgestellt für die
sogenannte cyberabwehr denn das sind ja
auch
Angriffsformen mit denen durchaus zu
rechnen ist also wir haben vor Jahren ja
schon umgestellt gerade weil wir die
Bedeutung dieser Domäne erkannt haben
sowohl
nicht der Verteidigung aber auch aus
Sicht sozusagen der Nachwuchsgewinnung
da tun wir eine ganze Menge da haben wir
auch viele personalverfahren sozusagen
abgekürzt Bohnen eingefügt wir haben
oder wir sind dabei eine Cyber Reserve
aufzubauen wo wir sozusagen Menschen die
in solchen Berufen in solchen Funktionen
und Fähigkeiten stecken die diese
Kapazitäten Kompetenzen mitbringen die
Möglichkeit geben dann auch Reserve
Übungen sozusagen im Seiteneinstieg zu
machen die vorher gar nicht gedient
haben also wir öffnen uns da in alle
Richtungen wir müssen sozusagen diesen
dieser
arbeitnehmergesellschaft müssen wir ein
Stück weit Rechnung tragen die Menschen
können sich das aussuchen die Menschen
wollen sehr schnell etwas erreichen die
warten also nicht mehr Monate bis sich
ein Arbeitgeber entscheidet ob sie
genommen werden oder nicht teilweise
geht das in wenigen Tagen oder wenigen
Wochen darauf müssen wir uns einfach
einstellen und reagieren was wir aber
auch tun ist wir wollen natürlich so ein
bisschen auch wissen wer dazu uns kommt
weil wir ihn natürlich exekutiv
Befugnisse geben wir stellen sie mit der
Waffe sozusagen auf die Straße und
bestimmte Aufgaben zu tun und da hätten
wir gerne auch die richtigen Köpfe mit
der richtigen Kompass Ausrichtung und
dem richtigen Herzen das kann man nicht
hinter die Stirn schauen aber wir
versuchen da natürlich schon
entsprechende Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen
um dann auch sicher zu sein dass wir die
richtigen Leute bekommen würden Sie
sagen dass das Ansehen der Soldatinnen
und Soldaten in Deutschland sich durch
diesen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
verändert hat ich kenne jetzt die
jüngsten Zahlen ich glaube das wird die
nächste Prognose zeigen die wir dann
Ende des Jahres bekommen ich kann
zumindestens sagen dass wir im Ansehen
in der Bevölkerung noch mal gestiegen
sind was aber wohl zurückzuführen ist
glaube ich vornehmlich auf Pandemie und
die die Naturkatastrophen und
wahrscheinlich den Beginn des Krieges da
denke ich liegen Erkenntnisse vor das
ist sehr beruhigend das müssen wir
umsetzen sozusagen auch in Attraktivität
und dann auch eine entsprechende
Rekrutierung oder Personalgewinnung die
Frage Herr general hat man glauben Teil
wenn sie auf ihre Laufbahn zurück gucken
die ja nun auch irgendwie schon einige
Jahre andauert warum haben Sie sich für
diesen Beruf entschieden
ich bin gekommen als Wehrpflichtiger
1982 da kann ich frank und frei sagen
weil ich mich nicht drücken wollte also
diese 15 Monate das gehört doch
sozusagen damals zum guten Ton dass die
Masse der jungen Männer dorthin gegangen
ist ich habe mich dann verpflichtet in
die Reserve offizielle Laufbahn zu gehen
die ersten zwei Jahre das habe ich
gemacht wegen des lukrativen Angebotes
weil es natürlich deutlich auf den wer
soll noch mal was oben drauf gehabt und
ich frühzeitig innerhalb von zwei Jahren
Verantwortung übernehmen konnte und dann
bin ich auf aus Überzeugung dabei
geblieben weil ich eben diesen diesen
Weg für mich nachempfunden habe den ich
gerade skizziert habe dass ich also Teil
eines Teams war was etwas bewegen kann
es hat Spaß gemacht von der Technik es
hat Spaß gemacht von der Kameradschaft
von dem Umgang es hat Spaß gemacht durch
die Führung die wir geführt wurden wie
wir behandelt wurden und das war der
ausschlaggebende Grund mit dann dem
Aspekt des Dienst dass ich auch dabei
noch etwas bewegen kann etwas größeres
zu etwas größeren beitragen dass ich
mich dann verpflichtet habe mich weiter
auf zehn Jahre zu verpflichten und dann
zum Berufssoldaten überzugehen was hat
diese Meldung vor einem Jahr persönlich
dann bei Ihnen ausgelöst
es bestätigt viele Dinge dass wir eine
wehrhafte Demokratie brauchen für die
wir immer argumentiert haben für die wir
immer gekämpft haben
wo wir jetzt einen großen Nachholbedarf
haben diese Wehrhaftigkeit für die für
die Bundeswehr also die Streitkräfte in
Deutschlands wieder herzustellen dass
das im Bewusstsein bleiben muss auch
dieser Bevölkerung wenn dieser Krieg
hoffentlich bald zu Ende ist weil wir
damit Schlimmeres verhindern können ohne
dass wir riesengroße Lücken schließen
müssen Klimmzüge machen müssen Zeit
verlieren Einsatzbereitschaft erst
wieder erarbeiten müssen und herstellen
müssen und ich glaube das ist das ist
die die wesentliche Lehre
ich glaube das hoffen wir alle
generalleuten hat Markus laubental
vielen Dank für das Gespräch vielen Dank
[Musik]